people don't realize that red light and
benign near-infrared light good right
for your hand just like this this fact
could enable better faster and cheaper
health care our translucence
is key here I'm going to show you how we
use this key and a couple of other keys
to see deep inside our bodies and brains
ok so first up you see this laser
pointer and the spot it makes on my hand
the light goes right through my hand if
we could bring the blood lights down
please
as I've already shown but you can no
longer see that laser spot you see my
hand glow that's because the light
spreads out it scatters I need you to
understand what scattering is so I can
show you how we get rid of it and see
deep inside our bodies and brains so
I've got a piece of chicken back here
it's raw putting on some gloves it's got
the same optical properties as human
flesh so here's the chicken put it in on
the light can you see the light goes
right through
I also implanted a tumor in that chicken
can you see it so this means using red
light an infrared light we can see
tumors in human flesh but there's a
catch when I throw another piece of
chicken on it the light still goes
through but you can no longer see the
tumor that's because the light scatters
so we have to do something about the
scatter so we can see the tumor we have
2d scatter the light so a technology I
spent the early
part of my career on enables D
scattering it's called holography and it
won the Nobel Prize in Physics in the
70s because of the fantastic things it
enables you to do it light this is a
hologram it captures all of the light
all of the rays all of the photons at
all of the positions and all of the
angles simultaneously it's amazing to
see what we can do with holography you
see these marbles look at these marbles
bouncing off of the barriers as an
analogy to light being scattered by our
bodies as the marbles get to the bottom
of the scattering maze they're chaotic
they're scattering and bouncing
everywhere if we record a hologram at
the bottom inside of the screen we can
record the position and angle of each
marble exiting the maze and then we can
bring in marbles from below and have the
hologram direct each marble to exactly
the right position an angle such as they
emerge in a line at the top of the
scatter matrix we're gonna do that with
this this is optically similar to human
brain I'm gonna switch to green light
now because green light is brighter to
your eyes then red or infrared and I
really need you to see this so we're
gonna put a hologram in front of this
brain and make a stream of light come
out of it seems impossible but it isn't
this is the setup you're gonna say green
light holy gram here green light going
in
that's our brain and a stream of light
comes out of it we just made a brain
lays of densely scattering tissue seems
impossible no one's done this before
you're the first public audience to ever
see this
what this means is that we can focus
deep into tissue our translucency is the
first key holography enabling D
scattering is the second key to enable
us to see deep inside of our bodies and
brains you're probably thinking sounds
good but what about Skull and Bones how
are you gonna see through the brain
without seeing through bone well this is
real human skull we ordered it at skulls
Unlimited calm no kidding but we treat
this skull with great respect at our lab
and here at Ted and as you can see the
red light goes right through it goes
through our bones so we can go through
skull and bones and flesh with just red
light gamma rays and x-rays do that too
but they cause tumors red light is all
around us so using that I'm gonna come
back here and show you something more
useful than making a brainless we
challenged ourselves to see how fine we
could focus through brain tissue
focusing through this brain it was such
a fine focus we put a bear camera die in
front of it and the bear camera died
could you turn on the spotlight okay
there this do you see that each pixel is
two thousandths of a millimeter wide two
microns that means that spot focus full
width half max is six to eight microns
to give you an idea of what that means
that's the diameter of the smallest
neuron in the human brain so that means
we can focus your skull and brain to a
neurons
no one's seen this before we're doing
this for the first time here it's not
impossible
we made it work with our systems so
we've made a breakthrough just to give
an idea like that's not just 50 marbles
that's billions trillions of photons all
falling in line as directed by the
hologram to ricochet through densely
scattering made dense trees densely
scattering brain and emerge as a focus
so it's pretty cool we're excited about
it so this is an MRI machine it's a few
million dollars it fills a room many
people have probably been in one and
spent a lot of time in one it has a
focus of about a millimeter it's kind of
chunky compared to what I just showed
you so a system based on our technology
could enable dramatically lower cost
higher resolution and smaller medical
imaging so that's what we've started to
do my team and I have built a rig a lab
rig to scan out tissue and here it is in
action I wanted to see how good we could
do we've built this over the last year
and the result is we're able to find
tumors in this sample 70 millimeters
deep the light going in here half a
millimeter resolution and that's the
tumor it found so you're probably
looking at this he's like sounds good
but that's kind of a big system it's
smaller than a honking big MRI machine
monster MRI machine but can you do
something to shrink it down and the
answer is of course we can replace each
big element in that system with a
smaller component a little integrated
circuit a display chip the size of a
child's fingernail a bit about my
background I've spent the last two
decades inventing prototype developing
and then shipping billions of dollars of
consumer electronics we full custom
chips on the hairy odds of a
chuckle physics so my team and I built
the big lab rigged to perfect our
architecture and test the corner cases
and really fine-tune our chip designs
before spending the millions of dollars
to fabricate each chip our new chip
inventions slim down the system speed it
up and enable rapid scanning and D
scattering of light to see deep into our
bodies so the third this is the third
key to enable better faster and cheaper
healthcare so this is a mock-up of
something that can replace the
functionality of a multi-million dollar
MRI machine into a consumer electronics
price point that you could wear as a
bandage line of ski hat put inside a
pillow that's what we're building oh
thanks so you're probably thinking I get
the light going through our bodies we
even get the whole ography D scattering
the light but how do we use these new
chip inventions exactly to do the
scanning well the we have a sound
approach now literally we use sound so
here these three disks represent the
integrated circuits that we've designed
that massively reduce the size of our
current bulky system one of the spots
one of the chips emits a sonic King and
it focuses down and then we turn red
light on and the red light that goes
through that sonic spot changes color
slightly much like the pitch of a police
car siren changes as it speeds past you
so there's this other thing about
holography I haven't told you yet that
you need to know only two beams of
exactly the same color can make a
hologram so that's the orange light
that's coming off
the sonic spot that's changed color
slightly and we create a glowing disc of
orange light underneath a neighboring
chip and then record a hologram on the
camera chip like so from that hologram
we can extract information just about
that sonic spot because we filter out
all of the red light then we can
optionally focus the light back down
into the brain to stimulate a neuron or
part of the brain and then we move on to
shift the sonic focus to another spot
and that way spot by spot we scan out
the brain our chips decode Holograms a
bit like rosalind Franklin decoded this
iconic image of x-ray diffraction to
reveal the structure of DNA for the
first time we're doing that
electronically with our chips recording
the image and decoding the information
in a millionth of a second we scan fast
our system may be extraordinary at
finding blood and that's because blood
absorbs red light and infrared light
blood is red here's a beaker of blood
I'm gonna show you and here's our laser
going right through it it really is a
laser you can see it on this there it is
in comparison to my pound of flesh where
you can see the light goes everywhere so
let's see that again blood this is
really key blood absorbs light flesh
scatters light this is significant
because every tumor bigger than a cubic
millimeter or two has five times the
amount of blood as normal flesh so with
this system you can imagine detecting
cancers early when intervention is easy
or tracking the size of your tumor as it
grows or shrinks our system also should
be extraordinary at finding out where
blood isn't like a clogged artery or the
color change in blood
as it carries oxygen versus not carrying
oxygen which is a way to measure neural
activity there's a saying that sunlight
is the best disinfectant it's literally
true
researchers are killing pneumonia in
lungs by shining light deep inside of
lungs our system could enable this
non-invasively
and let me give you three more examples
of what this technology can do one
stroke there's two major kinds of stroke
the one caused by clocks and another
caused by rupture if you can determine
the type of stroke within an hour or two
you can give medication to massively
reduce the damage to the brain get the
drug wrong and the patient dies today
that means access to an MRI scanner
within an hour or two of a stroke
tomorrow with compact portable
inexpensive imaging every ambulance in
every clinic can decode the type of
stroke and get the right therapy on time
to two-thirds of humanity lacks access
to medical imaging compact portable
inexpensive medical imaging can save
countless lives and three brain computer
communication I've shown here on stage
our system focusing through skull and
brain to the diameter the smallest
neuron using light and sound you can
activate or inhibit neurons and
simultaneously we can not spec by spec
the resolution of an fMRI scanner which
measures oxygen use in the brain we do
that by looking at the color change in
the blood
rather than using a 2-ton magnet so you
can imagine that with fMRI scanners
today we can decode the imagined words
images and dreams of those being scanned
we're working on a system that puts all
three of these capabilities into the
same system neural read and write with
light and sound while simultaneously
mapping oxygen use in the brain all
together in a non-invasive portable that
can enable brain computer communication
no implants no surgery no optional brain
surgery required this can do enormous
good for the two billion people that
suffer globally with brain disease
so people ask me how deep we can go and
the answer is the whole body's in reach
but here's another way to look at it
my whole head just lit up you want to
see it again
this looks scary but it's not what's
truly scary is not knowing about our
bodies our brains and our diseases so we
can effectively treat them this
technology can help thank you thank you